when nobody on Earth knew who the [ __ ] I
was and I was doing wine I read Twitter
20 million hours a day to read every
single person's point of view on wine so
think about that for a minute nobody
knows who I am I started a YouTube show
and Twitter just comes out and I'm like
Twitter and there was a site called
semis.com which Twitter bought and that
became the technology that is Twitter
search so at first Twitter wasn't Bobo's
desktop and you had no idea what
everybody else was tweeting you would
just go down different streams you'd
follow people and then the search engine
for tuner came out it was profound it
changed my life and I was like wait a
minute anything and I was like wine
enter and be like Twitter was all
Silicon Valley so almost every comment
was going to Wine Country this weekend
all the VCS right and then I was like
wait a minute I could jump into this
like hey fancy VC of that because now
I'm learning that world if you need any
VIP tours and then it led to Consumer
insights I was like what are people
thinking about Merlot Merlot [ __ ]
sideways came out everybody wanted Pinot
Noir and Hayden Merlot so now that
dictated my content I do that to this
day to this day